from Raymond another Catholic question
but this this one's pretty good Michael
since you're a Catholic allow me to ask
this why do y'all worship false idols I
know the candle burning is from African
voodoo but Saints elected by men Mary
isn't divine you can't gain admission to
heaven through your works you do good
works because you are godly and saved
why do you call priests father they're
not your father God is the father then
you have an earthly father but priests
aren't him
sounds pretty contrary to Christianity I
don't know if Raymond is just some arch
Catholic who's trolling me with this
with this letter but maybe not there's a
lot of confusion about the Catholic
faith I think that's why the majority of
the mailbag questions are about that so
let's go through all of your objections
Raymond and I will dispel your confusion
beginning with candle burning as some
part of African voodoo the fluorescent
lightbulb is a relatively new invention
for most of history everybody everyplace
used candles to light the way and by the
way candle light gives off a much more
beautiful light than does Al Gore's
stupid light bulbs with mercury on them
so I think the candles are fine I don't
think it's confined to African voodoo I
think it's the way to illuminate the
world other than the Sun and the Son of
God Saints are not elected by men that's
absolutely true
very often people say well Catholics
worship Saints and that's idolatrous or
polytheistic or something
Saints are those who have everlasting
life in Christ
Saints are referred to in many instances
in the Bible and the church acknowledges
that certain people are Saints through a
process called canonization so that's
not all the Saints there there are more
people in heaven than the church is
called Saints but some we know are in
heaven and the way we know this is
because of the Magisterium of the church
that is based on a number of scriptural
instances but in particular Jesus says
to Peter you are Peter and on this rock
I will build my church whatever you bind
in heaven of whatever you bind on earth
will be loosed by bound in heaven
whatever you loose on earth will be
loosed on in heaven you
have the keys to the kingdom of heaven
so there is an authority that Christ is
giving to Peter and and then to the
Apostles to have some say and to to bind
and to loose and have the keys to the
kingdom of heaven so by definition
Saints have everlasting life we ask
Saints to pray for us now sometimes
people say you're praying to the Saints
you're worshiping the Saints that isn't
the case we ask people to pray for us
all the time we go in and we say hey you
know Bob is having surgery next week can
you pray for us hey I'm going through a
rough time please keep me in your
thoughts and prayers what you're asking
for is a sort of intercession but you're
asking it to regular old fallen crummy
people you're asking me to pray for you
I'm not even Catholic I know I am well
I'm praying for Marshall really for many
reasons not just as heresy and so why
would you be comfortable asking Joe
Schmo to pray for you but you're not
comfortable of asking people that we
know have life by definition they're
alive they're the people who are living
they have everlasting life
it doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
to me I think it's a just a
misunderstanding of what it means to
pray next point Raymond has is Mary
isn't divine that's true the church has
never said Mary is divine sure we agree
you're I think that's a straw man you
can't gain admission to heaven through
your works yeah it's also right the
church has never held that you can gain
admission to heaven through your works
the church has actually explicitly
condemned this as a heresy this was a
fifth century era was it was a heresy
developed in the fifth century by
Pelagius the Pelagian heresy why do we
call priests father only God is the
father if we call anyone else other than
our daddies father then that's
diminishing God I don't see any
scriptural basis for this at all the
Bible is replete with examples of people
being referred to as father who are not
literally the parents of children but
who are in positions of spiritual
authority and responsibilities just to
go through a few in Genesis Genesis 45 8
so it was not you who sent me here but
God and he has made me a father to
Pharaoh and Lord of all his house and
ruler over all the land of Egypt that's
Joseph in job I was a father to the poor
and I searched out the cause of him whom
I did
no in Isaiah in that day I will call my
servant le Hakeem the son of Hilkiah
and I will clothe him with a robe and
will bind a girdle on him and will
commit authority to his hand and he
shall be a father to the inhabitants of
Jerusalem into the house of Judah and
finally st. Paul and first Corinthians
says I do not write this to make you
ashamed but to admonish you as my
beloved children for though you have
countless guides in Christ you do not
have many fathers for I became your
father in Christ Jesus through the
gospel I don't think that all of those
scriptural examples are heresy or
blasphemous or disrespectful to God at
all you know one aspect of this where it
ties back to politics
is I reject ideologies per se obviously
we indulge them a little bit but the one
thing I know about ideologies is that
they're not true the reason that
ideologies are not true is because
they're rationalized abridgements of
tradition of reality they can't possibly
comprehend all of reality and so the one
thing that I know about religious sects
founded by men is that they aren't true
and they aren't true because I can
understand them and if I can understand
them then they aren't they aren't true
they're clearly founded by men I can't I
can understand Calvinism I cannot
understand the Catholic Church which for
many people would be the reason why they
would be Calvinists for me it's the
reason I'm a Catholic because if I can't
understand it then there's a fair shot
it wasn't founded by men if Noah nobody
in history has really been able to
encapsulate and understand this thing
it's a good evidence that perhaps it was
as it says instituted by Christ on earth
GK Chesterton converted to Catholicism
for precisely this reason he said that
all these different sects are attacked
for being too conservative or too
left-wing or to this or to that but only
the Catholic Church is attacked for both
at the same time it's attacked from all
sides which might suggest that it has
the the right idea and just to hit this
point because a lot of the questions you
brought up I think could be answered
with a googol result I I Google these
things all the time if you're worried is
that something isn't clear then I think
you should look a little harder because
shallows are clear
shallow religion is clear shallow
thinking is clear profound things are
deep and murky that isn't my line that's
the line of father rut ler it makes a
very good point if something is so clear
that you or I can understand it I'm
skeptical I'm skeptical of it and I
think we should approach our politics
and certainly our human interactions and
absolutely our are off or God with that
same humility
on that note I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show try to survive the
weekend we'll be back on Monday and I
will see you then
[Music]
[Music]